hi everyone
i'm sorry about the slight delay in my
starting
i can't hear you at all i've got no idea
what's going on
wave your arms at me if you can hear me
oh wow well at least i can see that
that's brilliant thank you very much you
are alive
hi hi everyone um so i guess you know
uh why i'm not there uh so instead i
sent my hologram
over i hope this will do uh it's kind of
like i'm there in person right
except obviously i don't get to hang
around with you the whole time
and annoy you i suppose that's a good
thing really but you've got me for the
next half an hour
i've got half an hour right is that
right everyone anyone
have i got half an hour yes i'm just
going to interpret a wave
as yes yeah how about that okay good
right
well we're gonna have quite a fun time
in this half hour i can tell you i mean
obviously
i'm delighted that i can uh i can come
and join you here at the end of jsconf
it seems like it's been a pretty
amazing conference so far is that right
again wave your arms so i'm so
sorry i just can't hear a thing at all
we're really good at technology aren't
we as
programmers it's brilliant anyway really
pleased
that i could come and join you guys
because i kind of feel like you
are my programmer brothers and sisters
oh it didn't mean to go forward in my
slides yet
um you know and i love sharing
programming stuff
with people who love programming that's
you guys right
yeah i'm just going to imagine
everyone's going yeah because i can't
hear a thing it's brilliant
um but before i talk a bit
about what i'm going to show you today
some creative programming i'm
going to do some live programming it's
obviously going to work
flawlessly um before i do that i'm just
going to introduce myself briefly so
this
is the creative javascript workshops
that i've been running
probably two or three years now it's um
something i love teaching because
javascript
obviously you all know you're the the
top people
in javascript but you've all been
watching javascript
rise uh to i don't know to stardom in
the last few years
uh and obviously in lots of areas but
the area
i'm particularly interested in is
creative programming so of course
you've got the obvious things like html5
canvas
like moving dom elements around with css
we've got all of those things
um but there's also just the fact that
javascript is so damn
fast nowadays right it's ridiculously
fast it's brilliant
so it opens up all of these potential
avenues for creative programming and
that's what i teach in my workshops is
what i've been doing
for years in loads of different
platforms and programming languages
and now of course taking it all to
javascript it's really fun time to be
learning this type of programming
it built into the browser so the
workshops
spun off a website called creativejs.com
hopefully you've all seen it i'm sure
you subscribe
and follow us on twitter don't you
no all right yes okay good so
i really wish i could hear you guys it's
just
it's fine we live with these uh
restrictions it would be boring wouldn't
it it was too easy anyway
creativejs.com there's a team of us that
post
all the fun things that we find on the
internet all the fun javascript stuff
uh you know creative demos and
tests and games and there's also loads
of tutorials on there as well there's
this like i said there's a small team of
us
uh if you were at css conf earlier in
the week you would have met
bell head and she's one of the main
people behind creative.js.com so i'd
strongly
suggest you check that out if you're
interested
um what else okay so these days
i can be a digital artist
uh and you know obviously you guys are
programmers but normally when i tell
people this they think
i just do photoshop living you know
obviously i don't do photoshop
um well i'll show you some of the things
that i do
here's a project called luna trails now
i love this 70s game
an arcade game called luna lander so i
programmed it in javascript
and i put it in an arcade cabinet you
can see it there
that arcade cabinet is just running full
full screen
chrome i put in some physical controls
so you can play the game
now cool part about this is that behind
you
uh as you play this huge plotter this
hanging v plotter plots the trails of
the past that you take in the game now i
don't know if you've seen the game
the idea is that you land your lunar
lander on the surface of the moon
so as you trade as you move your ship
and gently try and land it on the
surface of the moon
this plotter will mark the path that you
took and over time you can see all the
trails of people that have played the
game
build up over time it wasn't just
javascript there was a processing
element and obviously the plotter itself
was quite a big
electronics project that's programmed
with arduino i'm sure you guys
i think you all got arduinos didn't use
that right did i hear that right
yeah arduinos are pretty awesome so the
plotter that i made there
uh along with an engineer called paul
strotten but the brains of that
plotter is an arduino mega so now you've
all got arduinos i fully expect
you guys to be able to uh make one of
those next right maybe
maybe your second or third project maybe
not your first one
take it easy to go with but it's great
fun i love playing with electronics
next project i want to show you is this
one called pixel pyros it's a
digital interactive fireworks display
the idea behind this well we've got this
massive screen
50 foot wide we've got infrared cameras
that pick up
motion and i'm projecting these orbs of
light onto the screen and you can see
as people touch those with their hands
i'm using motion detection
to see where they've moved their hands
and if they if i notice any motion then
it fires
figures of firework this is a bit
complicated this project is
programmed in c plus plus uh using open
frameworks
uh yeah we just have the most massive
projectors
it's absolutely ridiculous and we're
taking it on tour in the uk for the next
um well between september and december
this year
really super excitingly i'm adding
lasers
so i've got to learn how to program
lasers in the next
few weeks be easy right how cool is
lasers
next time i present remotely i'm going
to send myself a laser version of myself
yeah
yeah that's pretty pretty cool okay
anyway
what's next okay yes so the thing that
this project are away from your arms hi
what's up you guys you guys are awesome
right um the thing about
these projects that i've shown you and
in fact all the projects that i do
they're all designed with code you know
so i mean obviously the web design
community has
come up with this brilliant new idea
which is uh designing
websites in the browser well that's kind
of what i do i design all of these
crazy projects in code um
sometimes i'll have an idea of what i'm
trying to attempt
other times i won't i'll just make it up
as i go along um
but it's this process this creative
process that
as programmers as jobbing programmers
you might have
forgotten you know we all used to do
this when we were a kid
little sketches and stuff um we were
used to being creative but as
as programmers i think a lot of our work
is like a list of check boxes that we
have to tick off one by one
i love getting back to that creativity
that uh
iterative process trial and error those
joyful
it's a really good fun way to program so
you probably have this message like
we're probably like us programmers we're
probably saying to all the designers
yeah learn to code and we're being all
snooty about it but obviously
um it's well you know i i i do a lot of
web design conferences as well
for designers and i've been telling them
to learn to code honestly
i've loved they've loved me telling them
that that's the
brilliant it's not just all about us
telling them
to learn to code you know we've got to
be willing to meet them halfway
so i say let's learn to get creative
because i think some of the most
enjoyable work that we do is when it's
this uh
nice creative process that i've
explained
so let's do some codes yeah
live coding on a computer that's 5 000
miles away
what can possibly go wrong it's going to
be brilliant
all right i can tell you're into this
right so i'm going to be using
uh remy's js bin romney are you there
it's remy in i can't see him is he there
no obviously he's probably gone to the
other talk that's
fine whatever remy we're using jsp if it
goes wrong we'll just blame him shall we
all right let's make it full screen so
i'm running this js bin it's a bit of
html you can see there
um it's just putting in a canvas
400 by 400 i've also got getting a
reference that comes you hands up hands
up if you've done canvas programming
before
view yeah it's pretty good fun isn't it
what we're going to do today are quite a
few who hasn't ever done any canvas
before
yeah a few of you all right well
what i want to do today is just do a
little bit of um
graphical programming with the canvas so
let's start
easy let's draw a line
yeah exciting i can tell you're excited
it's really hard to type with a slight
delay
so if i if i make a mistake then just
wave your arms in the air
until i fix it
it's gonna be brilliant it's gonna be
perfect okay so i want to draw a line
that starts at the origin
and like that and then i'm gonna do a
line two let's draw it along and down so
if you let's see
now we don't see any of that that line
yet until
we tell the canvas to stroke path that
we've just defined
there you go it's pretty exciting we've
got a line
oh yeah i can tell you're excited about
that wow you guys are awesome
right let's make a line that instead of
goes down into the right
goes straight say minus 70.
bit of a problem with that now we can't
see it off
the right of our screen so one thing
you can do with canvas which is pretty
fun is move the origin
yeah have you done this before yeah few
of you
the entire coordinate system so that
subsequent drawing
uh actually is in a different place so
i'm going to move it 200 along
380 down so now when we draw
our line it's in the bottom pointing
upwards we've moved
zero zero point to the bottom middle of
this
so what am i going to do with this well
it doesn't look like it but this little
line is going to become a beautiful tree
i know it's pretty amazing right so of
course to draw a tree
we're going to do um we're going to
impressive function which i love blows
my mind
okay right so let's let's
let's define our function well i'm going
to take take it
step by step let's make this a function
that draws a branch
and i want to draw a branch of a
particular length
uh i'm just going to indent my code yeah
because i can tell you're all
getting a bit disturbed about that yeah
program
must indent um and so now instead of
just drawing a line
of minus 70 i'm going to draw it minus
the length right the length of the
branch that i want and now when i call
them i can draw a branch as long as i
want
100 maybe oh there's 100 or a stick with
like 70.
i'm just getting a little delay every
time i type it comes back a bit later
it's brilliant
all right um so here's the scary bits
oh my god what if at the bottom of our
branch function
we make another branch
well obviously nothing happens it's an
infinite loop right it's going to keep
calling itself
the thing with recursive functions is
that there has to come a time
when it stops cool so i'm going to find
some condition in this case i'm going to
make for a new branch i'm going to make
it a little bit shorter than the one i
just drew
so after a while the length of that
branch will be so
short but i don't want to carry on
drawing more branches so
i'm going to test if the length of the
branch is greater than 10
then draw a child branch
indentation woes don't worry i've got it
covered don't worry everyone's fine
uh and instead of just drawing it the
next branch at 70
i'm going to draw it at length times say
0.8 right so that means that our second
branch will be
80 of the length
you can see that all of our branches
just stop at the bottom
um so what i want to do before i draw
the next branch
is translate the origin onto the end of
this current branch
i can do that with translate now
translate is always
relative to wherever the origin is right
now so if i move
the origin up by minus the length
then it means that when we draw the next
branch it's at the end of the first
branch
yes look we have a beautiful
tree now which way is the screen is it
this way is it that way i don't know
which way never is it that way yeah yeah
yeah i don't know i can't tell i'm a
mirrored it's very confusing
right so now uh and in fact just to show
you what that's doing i'm going to set
the line uh width to be the length
divided by 10.
there you go so you can see that the
longer the branch length
the uh the thicker it is okay
now we see a beautiful tree what do you
think
yeah okay very [ __ ] yeah let's it's
gonna get even better i know can you
believe it
it's gonna get even better so now these
branches are all kind of a bit straight
let's make them a bit bendy i know
okay so let's bend these up a bit right
now as well as translating the origin
you can actually also rotate it
and so i'm going to rotate the origin
well when you
use the canvas context command rotate
it requires an angle in radians so if i
wanted to do it say
10 degrees in order to convert that to
radians i'd need to multiply it by pi
over 180 i'm sure poo what's that
ah it's so hard to type from here and so
now
every time i draw a new branch it's
rotated 10
degrees to the right i'm going to
rewrite this
function so that we now pass in the
angle as a parameter
so i'm going to change that 10 to this
new parameter
and then when we call child branches
i can pass in rotation of the next part
there you go
maybe i'll make it 15. a bendy branch
okay this is not quite what we wanted
how about
at the end of every branch we draw two
branches
and we could do this just by uh copying
that
and pasting it and drawing oh look at
that whoa that's not quite what i wanted
minus 15. now one branch goes too
much goes right now this is probably not
what you expected to see right the
problem is
is that we're going to go all the way
down every right-hand branch
until we get the end and then we're
going to go back one to the left and
then back
one again to the other left hand brush
but every time
we're moving the origin to the end of
the branch that we're currently messing
with
so in order to fix that well what we can
do is before we start messing
with the coordinate system we can save
it and then after we've done
uh all of this messing around we can
actually restore it
and we have our tree yay
i'm imagining applause at this point i'm
just
i see your wavings i guess that's a good
sign
how am i doing for time i think i've got
10 minutes left so how about we make
this tree grow
and animates what do you think yeah
all right you guys are up for it let's
do it
well the first thing we need to do if we
want to make our tree
grow is cool if we want to animate it we
obviously have to draw it over and over
again
i'm going to do it the old-school way at
the moment using settings well
obviously you should probably use um a
request animation frame i'm just going
to use this
settings for call it 1000 divided by 40
milliseconds every frame that means it's
going to get called
once 40 times a second so now when i
define this function loop you can see
here i'm translating and drawing the
branch every time
but before i translate i have to do
a a save
and a end
so that our chord system doesn't get too
messed
up it's really hard to code from so far
away
all right um so now the tree's getting
drawn over everything but our tree you
can see it's not very interesting
looking
um i'll tell you what i might do just
while i'm showing you this
um i'm just going to call this loop
function once to draw our tree once
uh and i want to add a bit randomness to
this well i've got this random function
that returns a random number between two
numbers so i'm going to pass
in instead of an angle of
15 i'm going to pass it a random angle
between 0 and 15
and on the other side i can pass in a
random angle between
0 and -15 so our tree's looking a bit
worse a bit
rubbish looking to be honest but let's
add the
a bit more wideness in our angles
getting a bit better but the other thing
we can randomize is actually the length
of the next branch so i can make that
between 0.7 and 0.9 maybe
i can't see where my cursor is
so now every branch is a random uh
amount of the previous branch between 70
and 90 you can see it's looking a bit
more
interesting looking now our tree is a
lot more kind of beautiful looking
um might just make it a bit shorter
but the problem is is that now if we
want to animate this
well we have a slight problem
in that well first of all we're not
clearing the screen every time so it's
just building up into a mesh
let's clear the screen every time it
helps at all
so clearing in the size of our canvas
so you can see that every time the tree
runs
it makes a complete round tree which
you know it's kind of a fun effect but
that's not really if we want to make
this tree grow we're going to have to be
able to draw the same tree every time
right which is kind of
really hard and crazy um
i just saw that someone told me there's
15 minutes left but i've no idea
where he said that i think i've got 10
minutes is that right anyway
type in 10 minutes yes good okay right
um
so we need to figure out how to draw the
same tree every time so we need to stop
this branch function being a function
that
just draws a random tree so being a
branch
object that stores the data arch what
what data does
our branch have well it has um
it has a length and an angle so that's
part of our property so this this
wonderful maybe slightly nasty things
that you can do with javascript
is uh turn a function into a class
definition
now i'm going to make a new object which
is my tree and i'm going to make a
branch
and it's going to be like six
to be nice i should probably put in an
angle
as well um we're going to
probably well this is where i have to do
now you see it's actually an object it
has local
variables that scoped within here called
length and angle
that's good that's what i need uh the
other ob
that i need for this branch is children
because now i'm not
i'm going to store data for the branches
so i'm actually going to
clean down here that draws the branches
i'm having some problems with latency
oh damn it did that yeah is it too
really hard to control the mouse from so
far away
yeah cut and paste that up there
and um here
instead of just calling branch well
first of all i'm gonna make a variable
children
uh i'm just going to set it as a
property that is
externally accessible
but there we are and now instead of just
calling branch
i'm going to add a branch
object to the children
so every time i type there's like a half
second
delay before it comes back so that's why
it's
not quite slick as usual i can't quite
see what i'm
typing gosh live coding is hard five
times
um so there we are right so i'm adding
a new branch onto the children array so
this stuff here
i need to put instead of just having
there is this block of code i'm going to
put it into
a function called render uh
and obviously i need to uh indent all of
that stuff
yeah yeah i can tell you're getting
nervous then for god's sake man intense
right the only thing miss boring the
branch object that we're in
but we actually need to check to see if
it's got any children
that it has
then we go for each one of those
as well so here we
call in i got
this getting worse this latency oh look
i made a mistake
i made any mistakes i suppose i should
probably
add a semi-room probably see what else
it's complaining about
uh missing oh another missing semicolon
well
i like putting my semi-colons in so i'm
going to put that in
makes me feel better right so now what
have we got well we should hopefully
have a tree um and here instead of
calling brunch we should probably draw
our tree
no idea if this is going to work
probably made some mistakes if you
notice anything
wait let's run it should we run it see
what happens
it's the same as we had before except
this time
that tree is getting drawn over and over
again but in exactly
the same place so this means we can now
make this tree grow and i am running out
of time
let's do it see how quickly i can do it
well i'm going to make a variable
called growth oh didn't spell that right
fuzzy you know i'm vnc into this
computer by the way in case you're
wondering
i'm going to set the growth to zero in
the render function every
render come on scroll up and
i'm going to add a little bit to the
growth
okay growth plus equals 0.01
um and here and i'm going to instead of
well let's make us a local variable
called belim sorry about the meaningless
names
uh i'm typing a bit too fast to give it
sensible long
variable names growth times len so down
here now
whenever i return referred to uh to
length
then i need to change it to b then
okay that's probably all of it
now hopefully uh i've done it
i run now hopefully it should grow there
you go it's growing
it's grown oh it's not stuck a bit of a
problem everyone retrieves and stopping
growing everyone that's pretty serious
oh my god stop here oh i'm just gonna
leave
come back um oh i can see you appreciate
that thank you
if only i could hear you it'd be
brilliant so instead of just adding
point zero one to it i want it to ease
towards
there's this um function you can do to
make it ease towards
a particular position i'm really running
out of time
i don't even really have time to explain
this
but i'm going to want it to ease towards
one so now hopefully stop
is it gonna do anything
yeah so eventually stops when they get
that it doesn't look very realistic the
growth
so i'm going to oh you know what i need
to do i need to store which generation
we're in
it's getting crazy and then every time
i make a branch oh my god it's so hard
to do this
uh i'm going to store the generation
in a local variable there
and at the beginning i need to add one
to generation and at the end of this
branch function i need
i'm really running out of time and the
screen isn't updating fast enough
it's all going to [ __ ] so now hopefully
i should have a property
called uh gen as a property inside of
this
inside of this object that i can use to
know how far
down the generations i am now i could
use that for anything
uh but at the moment i'm going to use up
here to set a delay
and i'm going to set that to be gen x 10
and so now down here instead of just
adding
anything to the growth i can say if
oh if delay is greater than zero
delay minus minus
that's where i can make the growth
there it is okay sorry i would normally
put that in brackets
so now hopefully uh the the new
the branches at the end should grow last
now
i have absolutely run out of time i'm
afraid um
but there is one here i was going to
make it sway as well but i've just got
no time
but instead i'm going to show you this
one that i made earlier which is using
exactly
a system but this has got it grows
uh it also springs and it sort of sways
a bit look at this
every time it does it slightly
differently and it's called cool render
style
now this awesome looking robo tree was a
bit of an accident really
didn't mean for it to look like this i
just wanted it to figure out how i could
draw a branch that was
fat at one end and thinner at the other
end and i got that system of circles in
there
and actually i just thought let's load
about my frame was nearing
yeah anyway i hope this has
been interesting i'm going to post up
all this code uh until you
look at you guys you guys are awesome if
only i could hear you
it would be amazing right um so that's
enough of the live coding now back to
the final
uh few slides in my presentation but
hopefully that's been
an interesting example of the sort of um
discovery these journeys of discovery
that we can do and
so where next if you want to do more of
this type of thing well obviously
that's creative.js.com also
there's a book called nature of code
which is by dan schiffman
a really really brilliant creative coder
he's such a good guy
and works mostly in processing actually
so it's worth looking up pricing there's
loads of resources about processing
but dan's written a nature of code book
which is pay what you want
but also he's got a vimeo channel which
is him doing all these videos of all
these
cool particle effects and graphics
generation
of generative art and all kinds of
brilliant
creative coding techniques if you wanted
to come to the uk
or europe you could maybe come along to
one of my training workshops
said lee slash training i am really
trying to figure out how i can make
these available to americans
uh with the problem that i currently
have
of my uh visa situation
well
so uh yes maybe follow me on twitter seb
underscore l y
um and you can keep tab let's
get with my visa application uh or also
uh if i manage to get any of my training
stuff online
uh hopefully you'll be able to now
um i'm in the incredibly fortunate
position where
i've been doing this creative code stuff
and obviously when you start doing this
stuff you can get
all personal projects um
but the internet is a great place for
personal projects you put them in call
on the internet
everyone tweets about it and shares it
before you know it you become known for
doing the things that you love doing
things that you do in your spare time
eventually end up
doing that for a living that's the
position that i'm in now
very fortunate to not have really any
clients anymore i just work on my
digital art projects and do these
conferences and
um workshops and stuff but if that's
something you're interested in then
you know you should be exploring this
stuff i'm sure you all are you've been
playing
mode copters and arduinos and all sorts
right last couple of days
yeah must have been pretty awesome so
while you're all excitable from the
conference don't give up
go home do some personal projects don't
just start the personal projects finish
them the reason people don't generally
finish personal projects is because
halfway through it just becomes work
right
and it always takes 10 times longer than
you thought so keep
my advice would be to keep your personal
projects kind of small
and buildable and maybe finishable
because if you don't finish project
there's no point
in starting it so do some personal
projects
finish them stick them on the internet
that's kind of all the time that i've
got all right now i'm so sorry i can be
in that there in person i hope this was
the next best thing
uh i've really enjoyed showing you uh
some creative coding techniques and i
hope
that you're going to carry on follow you
know
catch me on twitter tell me what you've
been doing share the work you've been
doing i'd really love to see it
and maybe next year i'll be there in
person but until then
i'd just like to say thank you so much
it's been great to virtually meet you
you